philly thank you for another weekend of
great shows austin texas headed your way
september 2nd and 3rd that's labor day
weekend vancouver september 15th through
the 17th in edmonton i'll be back up
there september 29th through october 1st
get your tickets to those shows and all
shows on my website at ryansickler.com
[Music]
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan stickler on all your
social media i want to thank you guys
for your support of the show if you are
watching on youtube hit that subscribe
button please it's a free way to help
the show it really does make a
difference for us all right
if you gotta have more
and i don't blame you check out the
patreon it's called the honeydew with
y'all and i'm highlighting the lowlights
with you all
your stories are
there's nobody that can hang with these
goddamn stories every week my mind is
blown it's five bucks a month if you
sign up for a year you get over a month
free you're getting the honeydew a day
early you're getting it ad free and
you're getting it at no additional cost
all right if you or someone you know has
that story has to be heard please submit
it to honeydewpodcast
gmail.com alright now the night pants
nation tour continues to roll on
thank you guys for your support we're
out there killing it i love seeing your
faces in august august 5th through the
7th i'll be at the la jolla comedy store
uh august 18th through the 20th i'm in
philadelphia and uh september 2nd and
3rd i'm down in austin for labor day
weekend so get your tickets to those
shows and all shows on my website at
ryanstickler.com now you guys know we do
over here
uh i always say these are the stories
behind the storytellers we are
highlighting
the low lights and today i'm very
excited to have this guest first time
here on the honeydew ladies and
gentlemen please welcome fahim anwar
welcome to the honeydew thank you thank
you i'm glad to be here of course thanks
for having me um before we get into what
we are going to talk about today please
plug promote all of it all that uh all
that the biggest thing is the special
that i just put out on my youtube
channel called hat trick i filmed it at
the comedy store so i do all three rooms
i did it myself
just in the era of
you know comedians taking the ownership
back and just sort of not waiting for
hollywood to give you permission to do
the thing
you know you can do
so i directed it i self-financed it and
it came out just really the way i'm so
proud of it and i just want people to
catch it so it's called hat trick it's
at
youtube.comore
all right and then socials and all that
stuff but hat trick is the big one
that's all i care about all right
um
well i you know i ask everyone to send
me what they want to talk about before
and yours already struck a chord with me
because it was about your grandmom
so before we talk about her
i mean what we're going to talk about
tell me a little bit about you which
you're originally from seattle yeah
tell me a little bit about your family
background and what sort of role she
played in that
so
yeah from seattle my parents are from
afghanistan um mom and dad mom and dad
from afghanistan and then you know they
came over here i was born in seattle
and my grandma lived in seattle as well
and it was tough because like she was
a fixture of my life and everything but
there is this language barrier so it's
almost like
you're missing an entirely like an
entire facet of communication and
she's from afghanistan afghanistan
english
got so like it got good to a point you
know but at a certain age it's kind of
hard to pick it up
so that was just something that
always tore at me too because me and my
brother never really learned the
language either um
whose mom is this your dad are you my
mom's your mom's mom okay um
because like other kids our age and
stuff and like you know our cousins and
stuff they speak farsi a lot better than
me and my brother
and i was kind of envious i wish that we
were able to speak it as well too
because then i would
be able to have an even deeper
relationship with my grandma other than
like
pleasantries you would do like
boilerplate stuff when she would come
over and we would like hug and be like
salam you know it's almost like a script
you know but that's all i
knew or had as an entry point to my
grandma i would hug her and stuff like
that but like i couldn't get into the
nuances of what happened at school or my
mom
would kind of be a translator a bit and
that would help
but
yeah i was just tough in that regard and
i think part of the reason i mean what i
always hear from my parents as to why we
didn't really learn farsi is because
my brother spoke kind of late like he
wasn't speaking in his development
and like he should have been speaking by
a certain point and then the doctor said
oh he must be confused by the two
languages in the house
so you should probably just stick to
english
because like it was more important for
my brother to speak than to be bilingual
so my parents were just kind of worried
and so just english in the house and
then when i came came along
everyone was just speaking english so
and then my mom tried to teach it to us
later
but then we just wanted to play outside
for the summer and stuff so it would be
it'd be like
trying to do homework during the summer
time where you just wanted to play so it
was harder when you're more stubborn and
older
so yeah so he just didn't have that
common
thread of language which sucks so what
connection did you have
just like
did you play games checkers chess cards
anything to like sit around and just be
around her and just be around and like
the energy and the calming energy of
your grandma and stuff and
again even
even having that script was
nice and knowing that she knows what
salam is and i know that at least
um
yeah and just she lived so long um
like 90 something it's one of them yeah
well the thing is with afghanistan they
didn't keep great calendars and stuff or
like you don't even know the exact
birthday because she could be seven kind
of or like 200 or something
cause you're like well how old is bb
john and they're like baby john she
might be
might be she might be 92 or 110 like we
don't know
but she lived a long life you know
and just having that as a fixture in
your life and
i'm 38 like
this is like the first time that i've
kind of encountered death so
like i've i'm very privileged in that
regard you know it's the first person
major death in your life at 38 yeah wow
yeah i mean my grandpa passed away too
but i didn't see him as much
how old were you when that happened i
was younger i was maybe like
uh maybe like 16 or something or yeah
but this like i saw people john all the
time like almost every weekend this is
something you really feel sorry yeah and
miss
yeah so she passed away when very
recently like actually louis anderson's
i think shares the same same like that
same day yeah she was a big louie
anderson fan so are you being serious
like my grandmother only english speaker
louie anderson
coming to america
um
yeah it was just so so she's present
your entire life present my entire life
and was she with it still at her age
like
um you know what what point you know
what i mean was she still there together
no towards the end like uh pretty pretty
much but she would kind of forget
sometimes some some things and
eating was a little harder towards the
end too and
my mom would go more regularly to to see
her you know um
did you
i would see her like maybe twice twice a
year i would go visit um the bay area
i'm gonna do that this weekend my
cousin's getting engaged so like i've
always been up there and caught her and
yeah it's gonna be weird not
seeing her this time for the first time
yeah because she's at every one of these
events huh yeah or at somebody's house
and like you you say hi to everybody you
said say hi to bb john
um
we might all go to you know the grave
and
para respects and stuff but
it's gonna be especially hard for my mom
too you know
also it's like the first time i've seen
death
that close up i've been pretty shielded
from it or like
death is a concept kind of you know
but like
i don't
i don't know how americans do it but
this is kind of like
i've been on the sidelines of when like
an afghan person dies or whatever but
there's like an islamic way of doing it
so which is what i mean i'll tell you my
experience i only knew kind of like a
little bit of stuff but like when it
happened i was in it and i i wasn't
privy to like all the specifics of it
until it happens
to kind of like your nuclear family
um
so like you go to this masjid which is
like a mosque so
we all go there and and the the bodies
there
in in the back and like
you have to wash the body like there's a
certain way of preparing the body before
there's like a set
set rules before you get buried
and so someone has to like you know
prepare and like wash the body and it's
this woman who does that that's just
like her thing and you think
you don't really think about that person
until
it's affecting your life and your family
and you think what what a saint
you know what i mean
some people wouldn't be able to
handle that and it's somebody else's
it's not even their family but
something that they're doing that's such
a major thing to think like god bless
this lady who helped out with that and i
think the daughters helped as well
and there's no fancy coffins or anything
it's very minimalist and it's in this
box um
this kind of like sturdy cardboard box
and
it's such a mind [ __ ] like
because she has to be loaded onto the i
don't even know like the fact that i'm
explaining it i'm like am i saying
there's a lot of layers here there's
almost like therapy like
you ever remember um
the world's greatest magic on fox back
in the day this is valentino and he's
giving away all these secrets and he
wears this mask and magicians are like
he shouldn't be saying those secrets
like this
that's why i'm a little hesitant to this
because like it's a dichotomy of like
afghan
culture where
it is all about appearances and am i
saying too much about my grandma should
nobody know about this but then it is my
experience too and there is something
beautiful about it
um
i don't think what i'm doing is wrong
but that's always like a pressure just
like it's very it's really interesting
yeah like no one should know about these
that culture you don't talk about this
at all
i mean we experienced it we don't what
i'm saying you don't talk to your dad or
your brother or your mom like like the
conversation we're having right now you
don't have that kind of talk about her
or death like that
no no not really because you're not
supposed to or just because you're not
that kind of family because some dads
are still out there with the like you
know patch on the shoulder don't cry
macho [ __ ] other ones are like me
i'm crying at commercials and [ __ ]
yeah it's sliding down the slide boards
and [ __ ]
it's not a spoken thing to like don't do
this or whatever but like you kind of
pick it up by actions
and you just kind of know the way to
like
like my dad doesn't say i love you you
know like when you leave here no one's
gonna you shove a sword through i don't
know i know i know i love it
you know what you talked about
yeah
so i need to get i need to like get over
it so well this is interesting to me so
you're you are battling with even
talking about it right now
yeah
yeah cause i don't know yeah so
preparing the body washing and put it in
the box and all that and then it's just
such a mind [ __ ] that we're all we're
waiting for the hearse we're waiting for
the hearse to come and then
to load up
and that's [ __ ] crazy to think about
like load up
load up
you know my grandma or like a human
being and
i'm right there with i've been a
pallbearer so many [ __ ] times like i
should get a free casket for real i've
carried so many [ __ ] dead
bodies bro to their whole like i threw
down the island church yeah like you put
it on that little thing and wheel it and
you gotta shove it into the [ __ ]
hearse and i'll tell you something else
i'm gonna tell you all this right now
if ever you have to carry a [ __ ] dead
body and i'm talking coughing not
you know you just killed somebody you
gotta get rid of it you're on your own
with that
get the [ __ ] head in okay it's so
much lighter i promise you that head end
up there you can
take your time and grieve back your back
you're like god damn you've done it so
many times you have techniques we fight
to get that front spot because that's
the gravy right there you want to take
them and just glide them nice onto those
rollers like guys you see anger because
you got to pick up your option i made
that mistake you see a younger kid
you're like rookie
you'll get the hang of it stick with me
you're like maverick [ __ ] your backup
you're teaching the kids now
this guy's the best he's held so many
best
and so i just had this moment like my
cousin has also been a pallbearer with
me every one of these funerals and we've
had so many of my dad my grandmother my
aunts
cousins so many [ __ ] people have died
and one time was me and my two brothers
and my cousin and his brothers the five
of us and someone else there were six
total and we had we just finished having
crabs we're all sitting out in the back
picnic table and then my aunt said hey
we guys moved the table back over and
silently we lined up in [ __ ]
formation and everybody grabbed that pic
without one word being said
and we carried it and everyone just
started [ __ ] you could feel it
going right through the whole circle of
all of us started let we were laughing
out loud like dude we've done this so
many [ __ ] times doesn't it feel
good we just grabbed that picnic table
moved it professionally cut through
something so yes and everyone you could
feel it was
what do they say palpable you could feel
that [ __ ]
i'm telling you it was there and
not one word needed to be said we just
started dying laughing like man we've
carried a lot of [ __ ] bodies to
their holes
so i
do understand and
you gotta
when my dad died the hurt the hearse was
full i had to sit up front with the the
driver i don't know who the [ __ ] this
guy you're doing like
um so is this the only one you got today
or
is this like a two for you going to
bounce around
it says your hearse is completing a trip
nearby
yo what if you pitch that it's like
overheard that's a good idea
you're about to retire you're a
zillionaire it's a pool there's like
four other
uber hurts pool yeah that's great
so she's and so now she's a warrior can
i ask you a question do they
do you pick an outfit because we pick an
outfit for that person to go off to
wherever you really do wrap the body do
you yes so it's like wrapped in this
white cloth just every everyone gets
prepared the same way
uh yeah so it was like
like a cocoon kind of yeah
and that was interesting because again
i've been shielded from this part of
life like death has always been just a
concept and when you're younger too it's
just such such a far away thing
um but then as you get older you're
you're faced with it a little more
constant
and i'm pretty lucky that i [ __ ]
lasted 38 before i was faced with it
like this
it's a hell of a run it's a hell of a
run
um and then you know my mom and and like
some of the other sisters were there
with bb john
um near the back you know saying goodbye
and
and the box was off and they're you know
looking
at her and they're crying and stuff and
me and my brother were
just where everyone else is in the
chairs just kind of waiting for the hers
to come and then
my mom's crying and she's like do you
want to
like do you want to see baby john
and it's it's tough because it's almost
like do you want it's like you're 13
years old in the woods or something like
yeah that's my grandma but then it's
like a dead body too and it's a lot
it's a lot to unpack
and like i i like to shield myself from
that type of stuff i don't i don't
really like watching horror movies
it's fun for some people i just don't
like feeling a certain way
and like my gut said i don't want i
don't want to see that you know
but then it's
something inside of me said like you
need you need to see this like you can't
hide from this um
and my mom's crying too you know and
like
and i could tell like she kind of needed
it too like that would have like if i'm
if i said no to be that selfish and to
be like no i don't want to see baby john
like
i don't want to be that guy or
she didn't raise me to be that you know
so this thing of like almost jumping off
a cliff like i have i have to see and
i'm never going to see her again and
this is part of it and like as much as
it feels weird and all this [ __ ] it's
it's a part of life and you can't put
your head in the sand like i n i need to
see john
so then you know i walk i walk to the
back and then
they like uncover and i look at her and
and they're crying and it's so it's this
other thing too where like you're
already feeling all these things and
then
your mom you don't want to see your mom
oh you know what i mean like that almost
hurts more than what i'm dealing with on
my own like
mine is so minor compared to like that's
her mom mom that's my grandma but that's
her mom the reason you both exist yes
yeah and then i'm i'm looking at
at my grandma um
and she's covered in the the white cloth
and it's like wrapped around the head
and can i ask you like here we embalm
the body and put all that [ __ ] in
there do you guys do any of that or is
this no yeah we don't put anything in
there
um
and i'm it was so bizarre cause
it's like i'm looking
i'm looking at a representation of my
grandma
um
but it's not
it is but it isn't you know what i mean
and then
i mean i'm skipping ahead here but it
attaches to the thought like
when when they're lowering her we're at
the grave site and just me seeing seeing
her vessel
like the production and everything we're
doing it's like it's for us
i don't know why you never maybe seemed
so obvious but then it hit me until then
like
everyone crying everyone being together
everyone saying these words and like
these prayers and stuff and
like they're gone um like we don't know
what that is or where they are but like
the production of it all
we need it
we need it more than anybody it's it's
not for the person no they they don't
even know what the [ __ ] going on
it's nice to know that when you go the
people you love most will be affected
that much and be doing that but like
logistically we'll never experience it
we'll never
yeah
it's just everyone there needs that
um so that was that was interesting
yeah just just seeing like a receipt of
a life
you know
yeah and an approximation
of the person because like their
essences is gone
yeah
so that was kind of interesting
experiencing that firsthand
and you can't hide from that
you know and that that's gonna be for
all of us
it's coming bro yeah yeah it's always
undefeated
so what bothers you the most about it
like is that
have you started to really like
think much more about life and death
since this because you're this is just a
few months ago you're saying yeah
totally i mean what's it done to you in
the last few months
it just shows you that that is
you can't put it off you know a lot of
tasks and stuff in life you're like i'll
get to it later i'll get to it later but
that is
that is the finality of everything
and it it kind of helps you inform and
reassess
what do you want out of life what do you
want what's left to look like
um
so it did that it shakes you up a little
bit in that way
to deduce the most out of what you what
you do have on this earth have you
gotten a little closer to your mom or
any your brother or dad or anything i
think a little more i'm a little more
open with my mom we'll discuss things my
my mom will talk about
how she's feeling with baby john and
um i'll i'll listen and try to help her
with that um yeah when like whenever
somebody goes through something
you're a little more vulnerable and you
get out of your programming of just
doing the typical
and this is what's going on blah blah
blah bye
yeah she's going through a thing so
it's helped with that
and are they all still up in seattle
yeah yeah did you grandma ever get to
see you do stand up no no no you never
even tried to show it to her or anything
like that i don't know i wonder if maybe
someone put it up on youtube or
something and maybe she would just see
me like flopping around on stage or
something and
yeah i don't know
yeah she even if she saw it i don't
think she would understand other than
maybe the physical stuff
but she i don't think she was super
invested in my comedy career
what was she like
just so sweet like quintessential
grandma like but did she have like uh
did she drive did she have she didn't
drive did she have her own she has a
community what's interesting is even
though um
you know your english may not be the
best sometimes there's other elderly
people and there may be this language
barrier but they can't hear a lot of
them came here yeah yeah but but i would
go to her apartment complex and she
would have these friends as well and
then she kind of picked up golf
oh
she lived right next to this uh like
golf course this public golf course and
she got like a wedge and she would go
out there and i would love going and
and playing with her too oh she should
go
yeah we would go do some putts and stuff
like that
i remember my mom would take
take her to doctor's appointments and
stuff at every clinic
and they would have coffee out there
this is before keurigs all the kids we
used to have pots
in the in the waiting room and i just i
was like oh yeah i love coffee so she
would like help me make these coffees
and mix them half and half and it was
like the most delicious drink for me at
the time the struggles we face with our
mental health can loom large over our
lives maybe yours maybe someone you love
you've tried everything or have you mind
bloom is the solution for the next
chapter in mental health and well-being
mindbloom is the leader in at home
ketamine therapy offering a combination
of science-backed medicine with
clinician and guide support for people
looking to improve their mental health
and well-being mindbloom connects
patients to licensed psychiatric
clinicians to help them achieve better
outcomes with lower cost greater
convenience and an artfully crafted
experience to begin take mindbloom's
online assessment to determine if
mindbloom is right for you if approved
you'll schedule a video consult with a
licensed clinician where you'll discuss
your goals and expectations for mental
health treatment mindbloom will send you
a kit in the mail complete with medicine
treatment materials and tips for getting
the most out of your experience after
only two sessions eighty-seven percent
of mind bloom clients reported
improvements in depression and 85
reported improvements in anxiety listen
i've been hearing about this for a while
it's been floating around out there
and i'm definitely going to try it i was
excited when mine bloom reached out so
i'm absolutely gonna do this and i will
tell you uh how i feel after it it's
time to enter the next chapter in mental
health and well-being let mind bloom
guide you right now mindbloom is
offering my listeners a hundred dollars
off your first six session program when
you sign up at mindbloom.com honeydew go
to mindbloom.com
honeydew for a hundred dollars off your
first six session program today that's
mindbloom.com honeydew when you use the
bathroom you always close the door
behind you right i hope so you don't
want random passer buyers looking in on
you so why would you let people look in
on you when you go online using the
internet without expressvpn's like going
to the bathroom and not closing the door
did you know that your internet service
provider knows every single website you
visit and what's worse is they can sell
this information to add companies and
tech giants who will use your data to
target you expressvpn puts a stop to
this it creates a secure encrypted
tunnel between your device and the
internet so that your online activity
can't be seen by anyone i use expressvpn
on all my devices it works on everything
my phones laptops routers so everyone
who shares our wi-fi
can still be protected even if they
don't have expressvpn and the best part
is using expressvpn is as easy as
closing the bathroom door you just fire
up the app you click one button and
you're protected expressvpn is the
world's number one rated vpn by mashable
the verge and countless others so if
you're like me and believe your online
activity is your business secure
yourself by visiting expressvpn.com
honeydew today use my exclusive link
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n.com
honeydew and you can get an extra three
months free that's expressvpn.com
honeydew now let's get back to the dew
and see let me tell you something like
all my relatives my grandmom was italian
and spoke italian in the house and i do
wish we would have [ __ ] learned it i
wish just to have that
a second language but um
my dad everybody spoke english i
understood everything they said all the
time and they're gone and i'm gonna tell
you it's not so much their words
or vocabulary that resonates with me
it's that
it's i went golfing with her
she showed me how to make these coffees
i don't remember what was said during
those days and i understood their
language so but i do remember the
feeling and the moment you know that
experience with that person i remember
that and i
so i hear you on you wish you would have
been able to i know you would have got
to know her better but still even in the
long run you're what you're going to
remember are those moments yeah yeah
because that's like all we had that was
yeah actions are bigger than just
small talk or whatever and did you how
how far was she from you
she lived in the bay area
so an hour and a half light
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but i mean
as sad as it is and everything it is a
textbook death you know like you could
only hope
when it happened uh hospice you know and
that's the thing is when you're in your
hospital you don't
you don't you don't come out you don't
most people don't come out of that dude
i always i always think it's [ __ ] up
that hospital and hospice sound the same
so when you're getting the news
you know like hey we're going to take
you to hosp and you think they're going
to say atoll and they go it's
both words shouldn't start the same way
cruel it is cruel yeah it's such a tease
like
yes like [ __ ] he said yes
is there is is there the one person who
got out of hospice and that's like they
should do like a biopic that's their
story rudy
[Laughter]
takes all the things off and everyone
else is cheering them on
out of the chair
i say no to this place and everyone else
with the tubes are like
yeah
i'm going back to the hospital damn it
i'm not better but i'm too good for this
place
oh [ __ ]
um
[Music]
yeah i first experienced death
my very first experience seems like
maybe it was a little bit like your
grandfather's it was uh my
great-grandmom and um she was italian
first generation over here
and
they had a parlor and they were in they
lived in tyrone pennsylvania and they
had a parlor in their house like that
old room you know they called a parlor
and
they [ __ ] laid her out in there
so
my dad's like we're going to say goodbye
and that's his grandmother obviously and
i'm like we're like okay and i'm
i don't know i might been to my
daughter's age 7 8 somewhere around
there
and we get there and i just remember all
the people in the room
you know you feel that somber energy you
know you're not
you know blind to that at any age
and i see um the coffin and we're in the
house
and there's a dead person like right
there in the house to her house
i'm like what a [ __ ] and as i get
older i'm still like what a weird
thing to experience
in the house you know and then i
remember
i don't know why it stuck with me they
gave me a cookie monster stuffed animal
or whatever the hell stuffy and i slept
with that
and that was sort of their like
you know
it's not not too scary yeah
you get something out of it
yeah i i i not until i got older because
then the deaths kept coming quickly
after that my dad died when i was 16 my
grandmother was a few years after that
my other grand my
girl was like my sister was a couple
months after that my other grandma was a
couple months after that i was like bang
bang bang bang and all of them were very
similar in the process of
of viewing you go to a viewing first you
know um
and they usually do two a night they'll
get we will get like it's a comedy show
there's an early show on a late show
yeah brother it's a two-drink minimum
you're gonna be there on wednesday we're
gonna we're gonna look at faheem at
seven and nine okay the family can come
in at six to get get get out of their
system first yeah get the good seats and
then be able to receive you know
while this dead person's up here
embalmed
from my experience they don't look like
they [ __ ] looked they looked they'd
look like a [ __ ] swollen you know
like you put a bunch of [ __ ] in them
is that commonplace to embalm is that
like an american type or i don't know if
it's an american type but it's
definitely commonplace at all the
funerals i've been to and i'll tell you
here i don't know if it's a i just think
it's american um but i went to a lot of
catholic funerals so it's always mass
first
um and then people get up and say
whatever and then it's then it goes to
the hole and you throw the [ __ ] dirt
and then they lower it and off you go
um
but
it was seven and nine
of viewing on tuesday and then another
one on wednesday at seven and nine and
then thursday would be the funeral
and then that's when you see it's
it's a process you know and then you're
going to the funeral and then that
happens and then then you go to the wake
and that's where
everybody has ham and cold cuts and
tries to get a little laugh and a smoke
and a drink and a lot of tears too but
you know that's the little that's a
little celebration of life some punch
and [ __ ] yeah yeah i see but you find
the cool kids at that and you go over
there how you doing
there was a moment uh you know when
we're waiting for the hearse and it's
all the masjid the mosque
there's because it's a mosque there's
prayers going on
some of the family would go in and it's
carpeted you take your shoes off and you
go in and
it's this thing because me and my
brother were like adjacent we didn't
learn all the stuff but we're we pick up
some things and then there's kind of
this
obligation or you wanna
i wish it was like the matrix where i
just put like an aux cable in my brain
and just know all the things that i'm
supposed to do
to give everything
just to be be good for this moment you
know
because the the cousins and stuff who
know the stuff they go in and they take
their shoes off and they know all the
prayers and there's the call the prayer
and stuff and they know the timing of
all because it's like choreographed it's
and me and my brother are in there
because everyone else did it would be
weird if we're just it seems like maybe
we don't care but the thing is we don't
know the stuff so so we go in as well
and it's one of those things where you
just
like we don't know we're like looking
over for the crouching and the bending
over and the hands and all that doing an
approximation of of the prayers
just
yeah it's like trying to dance and not
knowing how to dance you know
yeah i do i i there's a lot of movement
in the catholic church growing up and i
never knew when to sit kneel yeah yeah
okay same thing
i'm like what is this what are you all
saying back to this guy right now yeah
so you're sitting church the whole time
never like this yes like that's awesome
with you i would just try yeah well
we're kneeling now oh we're kneeling now
your peripheral vision probably got
great i would sit on the edge of the pew
too so i didn't have to kneel like his
other thing then he met pads on it man
there's all this money we're donating
this jerk where's it going um has your
grandmother's death made you think
you've been shielded i'm saying 38 is a
phenomenal run bro have you
forget about your death for a moment
have you thought more about your parents
going are your parents still together
yeah yeah they are have you thought more
about their passing
yeah cause
you know it's a progression of things um
yeah and how i'm gonna handle it and
it just it makes life uh
i don't know these these things that our
concepts are realities now you know
more and more and more
and maybe it's trying to
have more with my parents than i did
before like it's not like we've had a
terrible relationship or anything but
it can get very one note or you get into
a rhythm whereas
i have an opportunity
to have a deeper relationship with them
with this new knowledge and stuff or
faced with it i mean it sounds dumb like
new knowledge like how do you not know
this but it's different when you're
confronted with it
even my dad like me and my mom have had
a pretty good relationship like i've
been a mama's boy and i've been able to
talk to her and she's shown me love my
whole life and
she'll say i love you and i know my dad
loves me but he doesn't explicitly
say i love you i don't need that from
him or anything but it's just more like
fatherly
um
but it seems like it goes back to that
hole you don't talk about this time you
share your business you keep your
feelings to yourself yeah don't show
weakness kind of and then when i
remember when i moved to l.a you know i
packed up the toyota corolla and it's
i'm saying you know bye
so i'm saying my mom's a wreck and all
that and then
and then my dad
he just kind of like quickly went to the
bathroom because he was crying you know
yeah um
and then and then like after he was done
or then he came out and but it's one of
those things where it's so interesting
to me um
[Music]
that everyone knows like
you know everyone knows what's happening
but it's still
preferable to do it behind closed doors
in a bathroom than
you know in person
and that's
that's rubbed off on me like whether i
like it or not i i have that and i'm
trying to
break that cycle some i'm trying to be
somewhere in between my
dad and my mom you know
um and then like i would talk to my
phone or my mom a lot on the on the
phone
and then my dad not so much because he's
so old-school he didn't have a cell
phone or anything and every now and then
i would call my dad just to catch up but
he ju like and then when he finally got
a cell phone he got a pay-as-you-go cell
phone
because he's so about value and stuff
and and money and
that uh i wouldn't be able to get a hold
of him all because his cell phone it was
just pay as you go and he wouldn't want
to burn minutes and stuff
so and it would never be on because he
would power it off you want to conserve
energy and all this
so i would get little touchstones of
talking to my dad but my dad got an
iphone maybe
maybe a few months ago or like a year
ago
and we talked way more
and had i known this i would have just
[ __ ] bought him an iphone
five years ago or six years ago just to
be able to like
because it's so easy you know it's
unlimited minutes
he'll send a text it's almost like a 13
like
i can talk to my dad a lot more whereas
before was more of a production and just
like um
if it's done a certain way you don't
really break out of it you know
it's because i would talk to my mom and
then like you wanna talk to your dad hi
dad how are you doing
but that'd be maybe once every
three weeks or something and my mom
would be like you know two two times a
week
yeah so that's been great just the fact
that
my dad and i have a more open
relationship
just because he got an iphone technology
technology and also i'm further along in
my career now whereas
that was such a sticking point for so
long because we were like professor
xavier and magneto
justin like there's a love there but
we're diametrically opposed as to what
you should be doing with your life and
career
because comedy was not
something that i should be doing and
like we would fight over that and
i should like i so much wasted potential
really he would you would get that yeah
like i should be a doctor i should be
because i could i could what's your
brother do he's a dentist
but he did something
yeah
i'm sort of grateful for my brother to
have all right he's the winning horse he
he
i'm the second child i can be a little
more of a loose cannon as you do your
teeth
yeah he does help me out like uh well i
get cleanings here in la but if i need
like an impression or i need a retainer
or something come on i got a bro yeah
exactly
i get to visit my bro get some free
dental work where is he up there as well
yeah look he's up there does your mom
and dad go to him yeah all right i was
gonna say you better be proud
i think he has pictures online that you
could check out
no i've always talked like this
just
proud of your son but ashamed of his
dental work
yeah if you call his office um he has so
many open so many bookings
he'll come to you
he'll come to you you know like a fix a
windshield thing he's a mobile dentist
okay listen here's another one uber
dennis uber hers
you just have a cubicle jump and then
that doesn't have a toolbox
yo i had this
you can do that idea
from anywhere
yo i'm a dentist i come to you you're a
busy guy
do you need a root canal but you don't
want to take a long lunch
man this episode's full of gazillion
dollar ideas i had another idea where
you know how um
they have that like face opening when
you're getting a massage mm-hmm yeah the
whole thing so while you're getting a
massage you have a dentist come under
you
like a jiffy
so it's pleasure on the back and just
insane pain in your face oh yeah so
you're like oh yeah
oh god damn
that is good that is that's two for one
right there he's on the creeper
and he's in he's in like that full
overall thing his blood all over him
and then when you're done he's just like
all right so uh you're gonna want to
brush more uh you need to definitely
need to flawlessly this is the tartar
i hooked you up with some fluoride doing
x-rays underneath i want you back in six
months
that's good uh
yeah so yeah we were at home he's a
dentist you were at odds and i did
you know my parents were supportive of
me
i never asked he's an engineer okay
uh she was a
a nurse and then now she switched over
to hair like a few years ago and likes
it a lot more
but
like they supported when i did drama and
i would do
very they were very supportive when it
was just kind of like a thing you did at
school but then once
i started doing stand-up and it looked
like oh he may want to
do this more or maybe have it be a
career
that's when it was kind of like what are
you doing and
especially my dad
because it's kind of a shameful thing i
think there's a way of thinking about it
like
what will people think
and
he would always say this thing he would
say
people should be entertaining you
kind of like it's beneath
rather than i'm compelled to do this
thing and maybe i have these ideas and
it's an expression of me
it's less about that and more like oh
it's this low thing
and
you should be the person who goes to be
entertained not the clown the court
jester and the clown yeah
i don't know man i i hear what your
dad's saying when it comes to hierarchy
of things but for me
laughter coming back immediately like
these are different this podcast will
come out in a couple weeks whatever
the the rush of stand up for me is the
immediate [ __ ]
adrenaline you know right in the [ __ ]
vein good or bad you're getting a
response immediately and the laughter
back
is p i feel like they're entertaining me
yeah because they literally are
entertaining sitting down listening to
my [ __ ] and laughing at it so i i
still see it a different way i agree
with your dad
they should be entertaining us and if
we're doing our job they are yeah i
don't think my dad has that meta layer
it's not a [ __ ] i hear you on that
but it's not a ted talk sure you know
what i'm saying they are entertaining us
by getting the response out of that we
want is an audible laugh we don't want
people to go hmm and then leave and go
[ __ ] invest in some portfolio you
know we're [ __ ] i just want to hear
it now
see you later and i think uh
look stand up is an american thing
people cannot you could wrap your head
around it it's this american art form
and it's not outer spacey but to
an afghan immigrant
it's it's more clear-cut with status
sure
i was gonna ask if your dad had a
favorite comedian you know what's
bizarre as much as he didn't want me
doing stand-up and all that he's like i
love steve martin
he does he loves and
it's pretty impressive to me because
that is some pretty high iq comedy taste
for someone who didn't want me to zero
to that so yeah it's like i love dimitri
martin's earlier stuff earlier stuff
like that's a comedy nerd or something
second album not so much but first album
[Laughter]
so yeah he's uh it's one of those things
i noticed about
afghan culture just sort of
we appreciate art but they you don't
want your kids to have any part of it
it's for us to consume not to be a part
of but i think he's learning um what was
kind of nice when we were
at odds about this stuff over so many
years
is
occasionally other afghan families would
be like because i you know my career
would progress and stuff and they'd be
like you must be so proud
and i don't think that's a thought that
ever
i'm not trying to vilify like i love my
dad so much and i love my mom and i love
my parents and like this is just talking
about the journey and we come from
different cultures and i understand it
now that i'm older
because when i was 17 and we'd have
these fights and stuff
it's you you've got all these hormones
and stuff you think you think they just
you don't understand me and i want to do
this why isn't that enough but then you
get older
and i unders i understand it
so i i don't harbor
resentment or anything like that they
want they did it they came from a place
of them wanting the best for me
because they loved me they did it
because they loved me and they thought
this was best for me at the time
um
but yeah i like that he's getting to
hear those things and like oh you must
be so proud of your son and maybe
realizing
that the comedy and the arts and stuff
isn't just about status it's not about
just levels
you can kind of move culture a little
bit yeah because
can help people yeah and and even
say the perception of afghans in
afghanistan we are portrayed a certain
way on the news and tv and if you ask an
average american
what they think about afghanistan that
that's that weighs in the balance a lot
you're bombarded with negative
connotations about afghans and
afghanistan but then you have
me and my success and that's something
you can point to and it helps like it's
been nice to see the afghan community
kind of be like bro i love it's so cool
i love that you're on rogan i love that
you're doing these regular things and
you're not just
playing afghan weddings and you're not
just playing these niche that you are
breaking into the mainstream a change of
season means longer days better outdoor
activities and more ways to get
healthier including checking in on your
health and wellness with everly well you
can take action today by taking one of
their at-home lab tests or by adding
their vitamins and supplements into your
daily routine everly well is digital
healthcare designed for you at an
affordable and transparent price with
over 30 at-home lab tests you'll be able
to choose the test that makes the most
sense for you to get the answers you
need i took the food sensitivity test
came back with ginger and i think one or
two other things but
that's supposed to make you feel better
ginger makes me feel worse honeydew for
life y'all everly well also has high
quality vitamins and supplements to
support your overall health including
vitamin d3 and omega-3 fish oil here's
how it works everywell ships products
straight to you with everything needed
in one package simply collect your
sample and use the included prepaid
shipping label to mail your test back to
a certified lab your physician reviewed
results get sent to your phone or device
in just days you can even share the
results with your primary care physician
it's so simple over 1 million people
have trusted everly well to support
their health and wellness goals and you
should too for listeners of the show
everly well is offering a special
discount of 20 off and at home lab test
at everlywell.com honeydew that's
everlywell.com
honeydew for 20
off your next at home lab test
everlywell.com
honeydew for all of your summer travels
whether you're going abroad or staying
domestic and want to immerse yourself in
the culture and now is the perfect time
to start babel babel is the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions thanks to babel's
addictively fun and easy bite-sized
language lessons there's still time to
learn a new language before you reach
your destination i've been taking my
espanol y'all muy bien and i wish i mean
i took spanish in like 8th grade and
then 9th and 10th but it was so
technical i wasn't even getting english
all right so now i'm learning my espanol
and with babel you only need 10 minutes
to complete a lesson so you can start
having real life conversations in a new
language in as little as three weeks
other language learning apps use ai for
their lesson plans but babel lessons
were created by over 150 language
experts their teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be effective
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italian and german plus babel
speech recognition technology helps you
to improve your pronunciation and your
accent there are so many ways to learn
with babylon additional lessons you can
access podcasts games videos stories and
even live classes plus it comes with a
20-day money-back guarantee start your
new language learning journey today with
babel right now listen to this save up
to 60
off your subscription when you go to
babel.com honeydew that's babel.com
honeydew for up to 60
off your subscription
babble language for life wait
babel
language por vida
now let's get back to the dude you know
to have an afghan do mainstream stuff
i think is great um and i think my dad
is noticing that like oh people are
appreciative of this and has he had an
i'm proud of you moment yet
um you know that i'm
i don't it's the closest you got
for him he'll ask me questions about
he'll be like
because i got a nice car you know and
then i bought a house so there's little
life he understands um life milestones
so when i was able to buy a house
with funny money yeah
that is a real thing you can't fake the
funk on that
so i think he did some inventory there
where
oh wow okay because it's in front of you
before it was just sort of a me versus
him thing but
but that that's in front of your face
and you realize
okay
um maybe it is working out and maybe
my views on this can change a bit or i
can ease up you know
yeah but there's no like you're
you
i'm proud of you you haven't had the
shoulder grab yet
i know he is yeah i know he is though
he'll do these things where he's like
how's the car like my dad's i love you
is how's the car doing
the car how many miles and you oil
change your dude
yeah yeah yeah stop talking about the
car maintenance
and also
has he seen you live
just the apollo oh we're gonna talk
about that though no wonder
no wonder he's like you better
reconsider
before we get to the story about the
apologies i do want to end with a good
laugh too i want to ask you're 38 yeah
do you
want to be a dad do you want to bring
life into this world
i do um
i'm not in a rushed like my clock is
ticking i need this right now but i am i
do see that for myself
and this recent
uh bout with death doesn't deter you
from still wanting to do that
what that be a dad bring a child into
this world i think it it makes me want
to do it more
just to remind you and it's twofold i
think maybe my grandma's passing and
being confronted with death
um
that binary and then
also post-pandemic
i was 36 before the pandemic and then on
the other side of it i'm 38.
it doesn't seem like that much but but
for some reason 36 felt closer to 35
which felt closer to early 30s
and then 38's closer to 40 you know and
then
your grandma passes away and
and you think about the timeline of life
and you go okay
like
the bus is almost pulling out you got to
think this way you can't be a boy
anymore so if you really want these
things out of life
now's the time to
take some steps towards it
not like i'm going to marry who i see
the very next day but you definitely
have to have your thinking shifted and
calibrated in that way so yeah
yeah i think it makes me want it more i
was doing this bit where i'm like i
think i think i want to
i want to get married and
i go if you're not then you're just like
a guy who [ __ ]
you're the guy who [ __ ] all the time
like until you die
i go don't you want to see the rest of
life that's like playing grand theft
auto and just beating up hookers the
whole time
[Laughter]
well yo there's other levels there's
other things you can do like nah i'm
just gonna beat up hookers with a
baseball bat
like you're just gonna be a guy who
[ __ ] until he's 80 and then dies
you're just painting with red
that's a rat's grass that's great
your whole life you're painting with red
yeah you're like no i really like red
red feels good for a millisecond
and then i'm sad afterwards
but but that red for a millisecond
so yeah i think i'm i i do want that all
right um i want to talk about this
apollo story because you had said before
we were talking before we recorded that
you had a story to tell me about the
apollo and it makes me laugh that your
father the whole time has been telling
you
you shouldn't be doing this [ __ ] and
this is the only show he went to see so
what happened
i've told this a few times but
it it is kind of formative it was um
maybe i was a few months or a year into
doing stand up oh already at that point
yeah that's a recipe for zombies
um
and so the i was going to community
college i was going to
bellevue community college i think so
i'm in the cafeteria and then i see this
bulletin board for some flyer
and i i go up to it and it says i've
been doing standard for a little bit you
know it says apollo
amateur night on tour
so i'm familiar with the apollo right
they're going to all the major cities
and they're putting on a show
and i'm like oh that's awesome i'll
audition for this
the thing is i was okay when i first
started i was in a [ __ ] train wreck
i had some jokes and like i was pretty
okay out the gate how long is your set
uh
i think five supposed to be five or
seven is it a bunch of people going so
here's here's the process i you know
i rip off the thing
okay i got it
so the auditions are at the langston
hughes performing arts center in seattle
i go i go one day and then there's a
bunch of people just waiting to audition
mostly black people like i'm the only
comedian as well this is the only comic
pretty much yeah everyone i'm sitting
next to because everyone's like nervous
and waiting to audition for the judges
and stuff
they're all like dorami doremi they're
all practicing one lady was singing i
believe i can fly under her breath just
like see me running
and i'm just going over my jokes and
so then i audition
and i do pretty well like the producers
they genuinely like me it wasn't like oh
we'll throw them into the wolves this
guy's [ __ ] terrible
like oh that was great that was great
yeah so i get selected which is bonkers
i think out of
341 or 342 people
um i i got to do it so it was at the
paramount theater and i think that's the
biggest theater we have in seattle
and i think this is it so i invite
everybody this is such a
moment such a big stage such a big show
i invite
like all my friends from high school
some teachers come out
i invite my mom you know my family
and then you know cousins and aunts and
stuff so everyone comes and says pack
theater
and i remember i did a dress rehear we
did a dress rehearsal
and i was i opened up the set with some
hip-hop stuff i do some hip-hop stuff
and then talk about being afghan
i think in the middle of it or after
that and then the producers were like
yeah that's great that's great
we think we like you should open with
the afghan stuff first they're telling
you how to do your set i'm so young i
don't um
i go oh they they're the producers they
know i'm so green
oh yeah okay yeah i could do that i just
want to be a team player
i go okay i'll do that so then it comes
night of the actual show it's my i come
out
and then i start with the afghan stuff
and i'm like hey guys like my name is
raheem
it's a it's an afghan name to be exact
and we're like boo
no
hold on you walk out and say that and
you're literally i'm literally up there
for
six seconds
maybe maybe 10 seconds and all you've
done is introduce yourself pretty much
i don't know i'm so far away from it i
may be missing i just know it was very
short amount of time before the booth
started coming in so it may have
genuinely been that i was terrible and
it was just like bombing
but then it could also it didn't help
that i'm opening about talking about
afghan like on the heels of 911
you know that's not a great opener too
um
so i'm up there and there's like one boo
like
boo
boo and then it's like an avalanche it's
like a snowball just picking up stairs
how big is that theater like 4 000
people oh wow it's a stuff of nightmares
it's you're real uh yeah i've been on
those stages with segora so
i can't imagine imagine the highest
lines i'm saying being booed by that
you know how good you feel when you come
off those saguaros imagine feeling the
worst
even half of that crowd booing me would
[ __ ] make me feel like imagine
all of us
so i'm up there like
it's getting louder and louder and i
always say the thing with comedy and the
apollo is
you're done you get one boo you're done
with singing you could be you could hit
a high note and be like
you can kind of drown them out with the
music comedy he was like
yeah yeah yeah
and then the siren goes off like
not her pulling out yeah yeah and does
that clown come out
but the clown comes out isn't he a clown
his smoke breaks over he's like
let me hook you on the neck and pull you
out though well here's the thing i know
how the apollo works i don't need to
wait to get hooked i get off on my own
good for you
i'm not gonna [ __ ] get hooked rub
that stuff again yeah
i'm not gonna help you with your hourly
hook man
you're not getting paid off of me
so you go all the booze and all that
[ __ ] and then i don't wait to get pulled
i just i leave
and that is just so surreal to be
you know what do you do you walk off and
what
they have to sit there here's the thing
so
it feels like a dream that is an
experience
that uh i don't think many people will
ever have in their life
uh maybe you'll probably never again
either
yeah let's hope most likely yeah
yeah i think 20 years in the stand up
that doesn't happen anymore get booed by
four thousand people um
but there was a stairwell where i had to
walk back up to the dressing room and
[ __ ] but there was this little desk
there
you know those l-shaped school with the
basket underneath
it was there in the stairwell and i just
sat in
it and i was just shell-shocked and
trying to make sense of what happened i
go was that a dream
was that real
how does my life what do i do now
so i just chilled there for 20 minutes
just trying to
put your brain back together
and i go okay all right i got to get my
clothes from the dressing room and
there's the mental illness in all of us
right there the worst thing that could
ever happen to you but i'm gonna go back
out there and do it again
that's where it was that's what i
learned
and for his horror people be like oh my
god what a terrible experience and
i would never do it again and
but for that to happen so early in my
career
and the fact that i i hit the stage a
few days later
like oh i was born to do this like this
is deep rooted i can't help this this is
sort of like a shepherd dog just herds
sheep like it just
does that
most comedians will never be booed by 4
000 people and and and most of them that
had been
early on you said six months to a year
you're in all this [ __ ] like that would
make everyone stop it would make
everybody be like all right i'm not
going to do that i don't want to feel
that again yes i don't want to feel that
again
yeah where i was like okay this is what
happens i can i can change this i
learned i learned from it i took it as a
learning experience
and i think that's why i've been able to
i was watching this ted talk about why
people make it or break through and it's
not always talent it's this thing called
grit
grit is more valuable than all the
intangibles
it's just the perseverance
to keep going and refining and get
better
and when most people would drop out
because it doesn't feel good
to learn from that
welcome change hustle
all of it yeah it's all data
it's not
something telling you to stop or
whatever i mean every everyone's
different but
yeah i always took a learning experience
but the funny part of it which is why i
called my first special
this title is because on the car ride
home like my dad was so happy he thought
that the horse had been broken right oh
he thought he thought this is come on
it's almost like his prayers were
answered
it's almost like he probably started the
booth
[Music]
just to get it going it's like throwing
a cigarette butt in a dry forest
i know it wasn't my dad but how funny
would it be so it's completely silent on
the car ride home
because everyone's just like what the
[ __ ] happened and everyone's so
embarrassed who's everyone it's not just
your dad
no it's my dad well i drove separately
so i hear the story from my brother so
it's my brother my cousin nilo oh you're
not in the car
[Laughter]
it's unfiltered raw muhammad
[Laughter]
so you know no one's talking for 20
minutes and then he goes well
there's no business like showbiz
well you can't be mad at that no you
can't the timing the executions
[Laughter]
he's got it in the chamber well
there's no
oh
[ __ ] that is so good and so that was
just such a
hair harrowing thing
that i never let my parents come to a
show i just kept it separate
uh
and i was always looking for this per in
my mind i'm like oh i'll have them come
out when i do the tonight show or
something and
maybe i will i
because that's like a thing it's easier
things i've done two late nights now
i might want to just even though late
night doesn't move the needle anymore
not crazy yeah i know this is bigger
than late night for real i swear to god
this will do better for getting views on
my special than me doing stand-up on
cordon or tonight's show or it doesn't
matter anymore that's mind-blowing it's
mind-blowing um
but i might want to try to do the
tonight show just as a throwback and
kind of a celebration and the things
turned out okay
put a suit on
fly my parents out that might be fun to
do just to kind of close the chapter on
that i've always thought about doing
that that's nice but i got busy with all
this other hollywood stuff like i had
this writing job and i was trying to do
this special and i was still
in turmoil over about
that was so bad them seeing me and them
being so opposed to my comedy and that
experience was so
[ __ ]
that in my mind for them to see me
the next time i wanted them to see me i
wanted it to be so exponentially great
um so i've been waiting i've been trying
to build that moment what about like a
nice main room show at the store i could
do that yeah that i can't do that like
the more you wait
we just talked about death for [ __ ]
an hour you know you never know kind of
a breakthrough like
i was stuck in that routine and
programming and thinking
like i'm 20 because i've just been
saying the same [ __ ]
but i can't i need to do it i'm gonna
i'm gonna do it i'm gonna find a main
room comedy store sold out show would be
amazing they come out and
that room is such a great room you know
when you see it when the 50th
anniversary i thought they did such a
great job with the buddy rich band up
there where you could see what it used
to be like in the entertainment in that
building before
we started telling dick jokes in there
and stuff i thought it was pretty wild
it's just a classic venue you know what
i mean yeah it'd be cool show them the
name on the wall yeah hell yeah and they
could see
that's his history
you are part of comedy history
and you could show them that that's look
the tonight show's cool i know because
your dad probably resonates with him a
little bit from back in the day and all
that but your name on a building where
you worked your ass off to get in there
um and then you go in and do a show in
that main room and kill like you always
do i oh they would probably love that
yeah yeah and that's easy to do now
maybe i can work on this night show
thing and but like in the here and now
when they are in la i can bring them to
the main room and that would be fun yeah
um but i'm i i definitely need to get on
writing that wrong at least for me to
close that chapter do it
um
first of all thank you for coming here
and doing this this was [ __ ] really
great i also learned a lot i didn't know
it's the first time i've talked to uh
someone about other cultures and their
sort of um
i don't know what do you call it
procedures and process of death and
stuff
um all right i i told you before we
recorded this your first time here so
um advice you would give to your 16 year
old self now
um
it's it's a journey
it's a journey and also don't be an
island
collaborate have friends come up
together
don't don't
even if you like what you're doing you
think we're doing is great it's more
important to have like a knit crew and
friends and come up together
don't isolate yourself
great that's great and don't start with
the afghan material bro don't start with
the afternoon you you you slide that in
midway
never open with what you are yeah what
you are
uh one more time plug and promote
whatever you'd like please uh the
special it's called hat trick it's uh on
my youtube so youtube.com ximenor
and just my socials instagram
affiximiano or twitter email or
tick-tock for some gin's ears female or
comedy i couldn't get that one
and uh yeah just catch me live i mean we
do stand up we love seeing the people
when they come out comedy store or when
i hit the road this fall
all right yeah thank you again thank you
man and all as always thank you guys
ryan sickler on all social media ryan
sickler.com we'll talk to you all next
week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you